[Musique]
bon je vous remercie de nous rejoindre
sur tv soixante dix huit pour une
nouvelle édition spéciale le point sur
l'actualité dans les yvelines en cette
période de pandémie et de confinement
tout d'abord un chiffre 50 milles c'est
le nombre de masques distribués aux
communes de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines par la région ile de
france que ce soit à maurepas et long
cours ou encore villepreux par exemple
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces
différentes photos chaque ville a reçu
l'équivalent de 20% de sa population
selon othman nasri conseiller régional
charge maintenant aux communes de les
distribuer selon les priorités aux
médecins fermiers personnel en maison de
retraite ou encore aux agents municipaux
policiers et pompiers
au total la région ile de france a
commandé à ce jour plus de 20 millions
de masques
le coc vide 19 peut avoir des
conséquences très graves notamment pour
celles et ceux qui sont âgés ou affectés
par des maladies chroniques comme le
diabète l'obésité ou encore un cancer je
vous propose d'écouter à présent le
témoignage de claudine canal elle est
présidente de l'association les poids
plumes interview menée par nicolas
landry
bonjour claudine canal et bonjour
présidente de l'association poids plume
vous accompagner les personnes en
situation d'obésité ou de surpoids
une antenne est implanté dans les
yvelines plusieurs antennes d'ailleurs
dans les hôpitaux yvelinois alors dans
ce contexte de confinement de crise
sanitaire
comment se poursuit le suivi
thérapeutique des personnes atteintes
d'obésité ou de surpoids
alors bon comme vous le savez la
population des obèses c'est une
population à gros risques donc il faut
pas perdre le fil il faut vraiment
continuer son suivi médical
surtout qu'ils avaient komornicki
comment visiter qui sont associés
notamment le diabète une carnation les
problèmes respiratoires d'autant plus il
faut être vraiment vigilant et garder
contact avec l'équipe médicale je sais
qu'en ce moment avec la crise sanitaire
c'est un peu compliqué mais tous les
médecins ont mis en place des
téléconsultations n'hésitez pas à
contacter vos médecins pour poutine et
la suisse est super important il faut
pas lâcher prise parce que effectivement
déjà sur un abcès un abcès aspects
psychologiques les personnes sont très
fragilisées et si on ne continue pas ce
suivi qu'on a mis en place depuis un
certain temps et ben ça devient de plus
en plus conclut que le poids or il ya
différents types de suivi il ya des
personnes qui qui vont procéder à une
opération peut être dans les prochains
mois et des personnes qui ont subi une
opération
alors voilà alors les personnes qui
alors toutes les opérations ont été
annulés dans l'ensemble du territoire
fonctionne en face a été un message de
la sophro qui est la société savante qui
suit la chirurgie bariatrique chirurgie
de l'obésité est en fait tout est mis en
stand-by
les préparations sont mis aussi en stand
by
donc ça sera d'étaler dans le temps mais
il ya effectivement les personnes qui
ont effectué cette chirurgie site est
lancé au début de cette chirurgie de
bien suivre tous les protocoles qu'on a
mis en place aussi la alimentaires et
autres
attention pour l'activité physique une
activité physique modérée et douce dans
un premier temps si c'est juste le mois
après de l'opération ne pas faire appel
aux abdominaux parce que ça peut
engendrer des complications beaucoup
plus importante après aussi dans ces
conditions de suivi médical peut se
faire à distance
tout à fait et alors il faut contacter
le secrétariat de la chirurgie
bariatrique où vous êtes suivi où les
professionnels sont de santé il ya
beaucoup de professionnels de santé aux
dans le 78 qui sont en libéral donc je
vous invite à faire de la
téléconsultation en prenez rendez vous
sur notre solide une cire autres et pour
que ces personnels soient vraiment suivi
un petit peu au fil de l'eau quoi parce
que j'ai très peur pour la suite
donc on encore leur parlera aussi dans
la suite de l'interview mais c'est comme
je dis nous sommes une population à très
haut risque donc il faut bas mot en soi
le soir
voilà ça c'est pour le côté médical vous
venez d'en parler l'association poids
plume c'est aussi de l'accompagnement
sur la diététique sur le psychologique
et sur l'activité physique et sportive
comment vous vous organisez justement à
ce niveau là alors l'objectif
effectivement c'est pas perdre le lien
c'est que les jambes comme sont
confinées chez 2000 on tombe en dessous
et être à ce prix y est donc moi je suis
très inquiète pour les personnes qui
sont seules
je vous le dis parce que ben on a plus
tendance à avoir des fringues à bout des
choses comme ça et on va aller
effectivement on a des troubles du
comportement alimentaire
parce que l'obésité c'est très complexe
et pas seulement des troubles c'est
aussi la sédentarité donc et la
diététique donc ce que je vais presque
c'est de garder une alimentation saine
avec des produits frais favoriser
effectivement de cuisiner en famille ça
peut être aussi un rapprochement
et puis aussi de continuer bas tout ce
qu'on a pris en protocole fractionné au
lieu de se diriger vers des gâteaux
quand on a un coût d'ancienneté se
dirigeait plutôt sur des produits
laitiers sur
des produits laitiers sur des fruits
frais préparés à l'avancé vos fruits
frais pour effectivement qu'ils soient à
votre portée et que vous n'allez pas
perdre tout ce qui est une alimentation
très riches en calories en russie et
gardez bien cet équilibre alimentaire
qui est donc féculents féculents liquide
c'est-à-dire la viande le poisson et au
su et ensuite le liquide bien sûr donc
l'association effectivement tous à tous
les conseils diététiques psychologique
et activités sportives on peut le
retrouver sur votre page de facebook
parce que vous avez mis en place des
vidéos des ateliers en visioconférence
alors les ateliers diététiques et
psychologique démarre donc que demain
par un webinaire justement ça fera
effectivement des questions réponses aux
diététiciens psychologues et acteur
activité physique aussi par la suite
et bien entendu mais j'aimerais élargir
les choses en sophrologie en méditation
en beaucoup de choses donc c'est un peu
long à mettre en place parce que en
étant confiné à la maison et moi n'étant
pas une spécialiste vidéos et tout
système où les médias actuels
effectivement c'est un peu long donc je
me forme à ça et on va démarrer donc
demain par contre au niveau de
l'activité physique sur notre page
facebook les poids plumes france tous
les jours notre coach sportif le publie
depuis 23 mars
depuis début de confinement des
exercices pour que les gens puissent
mettre en application une activité
j'écoute régulière alors ne pas hésiter
à aller sur votre page facebook les
poids plumes ans et ça les couacs et
transmises que ça merci claudie canal
est né à fait aboutie président bon
courage et président prenez soin de vous
c'est important on a besoin de bourgi
merci que du canal et présidente de
l'association les poids plumes
nous poursuivons cette édition spéciale
avec le travail mené par le groupe
renault qui s'organisent pour répondre
aux besoins en matériel médical
plusieurs projets sont engagés la
production de visière pour le personnel
soignant ou encore la participation à la
conception de respirateurs le
technocentre située à guyancourt
participe activement à ces deux missions
nicolas d'andry de la recherche et
développement automobile à la production
de matériel médical
le technocentre renault de guyancourt
s'est adapté à la crise sanitaire du coc
vide dix neuf plus d'une centaine de
collaborateurs de ce site sont mobilisés
sur plusieurs projets notamment la
production de visière destiné au
personnel soignant
on a l'ensemble de nos maisons de
production d'impression 3d ils sont
habillés pour produire des supports de
ville hier à destination des soignants
on décompte plus tôt ces masques là pour
les filières là pour le personnel
soignant que c'est vraiment des matières
qui sont compatibles avec les protocoles
des questions 700 visière ont déjà été
produites sur les sites de guyancourt
flins et maubeuge depuis le début de la
semaine un moule a été conceptualisée
pour produire en grandes séries objectif
4000 visière minimum par semaine
moon qui permet de sortir une pièce avec
une cadence très élevée qu'on injecte en
fait en plastique dans un moule en métal
hier à pouvoir sortir à la suite
très rapidement on va permettre parce
que quand vous imprimez en 3d sur une
machine vous allez pouvoir par exemple
sur 24 heures sur les sur des matières
qui sont biocompatible sortir 60 unités
pour avoir une capacité de production
bien supérieure et en même temps de
libérer les imprimantes 3d pour la
fabrication kiev à destination des
restaurateurs c'est l'autre activité du
technocentre dans ce contexte de crise
sanitaire la participation à la
conception de respirateurs à travers
deux projets avec un consortium
industriel autour de michelin du seuil
de stmicroelectronics et d'une
initiative d'ingénieur à paris surtout
qu'on est là on apprend que des
compétences
compétences à charge des compétences
logistique supply chain réalisation
prototype également la partie
industrielle
le projet inquiète plus avancées
aujourd'hui on envisage une mise en
production vraiment sous le temps avec
une production de 5 100 respirateurs
jour dont une partie serait allé à
réaliser qu'on reste ont cessé d études
que nous avons en cours était consentant
cette situation est inédite une
véritable organisation industrielle
collaborative pour participer à la lutte
contre le coronavirus
entreprises et économie toujours avec le
prêt garanti par l'état c'est l'une des
mesures phares du gouvernement avec 300
milliards d'euros débloqués pour
faciliter le recours au crédit des
sociétés en difficulté
philippe mauron directeur du centre
d'affaires bnp paribas
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous explique
ce dispositif
[Musique]
aujourd'hui quand vous prenez la somme
totale des crédits de trésorerie de
toutes les entreprises en france que sai
de l'auto entrepreneur à la très grande
entreprise
la somme de tous ces crédits trésorerie
en france et 240 milliards et l'aida
amis on peut s'y bilité un prêt qui
permet de faire un bond sur des besoins
de trésorerie de 300 milliards payés 240
c'est quand même énorme le chêne
entreprise contacter sa banque pour dire
bah voila j'ai un besoin de trésorerie à
court moyen terme et nous on est là pour
les appuyer en disant bah voilà quel
peut être le scénario un petit peu
catastrophe prenons l'hypothèse la plus
pessimiste la ré ouverture tardive il
parlait de confinement qui se prononce
faut quand même l'avoir en tête
deuxièmement qu'est-ce que vous avez
encore en fournisseur a payé il va bien
falloir payer un jour ses charges
sociales ces charges fiscales et puis
aussi un autre sujet qu'on commence à
travailler c'est quand il va falloir
redémarrer l'activité de quoi allez vous
avoir besoin et les autres puisque ont
besoin de recréer du stock appartements
ont aussi mis d'accord entre clients et
nous surnommons tant qu'on peut financer
le client va sur le site de la bpi qu'un
site extrêmement bien fait il y voit là
la bnp paribas est prête à me prêter
temps de milliers d'euros là le crès
école c'était générale le 6 7 ans le
montant la bpi délivre un numéro
d'accord que le client nous communique à
partir de ce moment là on lui envoie une
offre de prêt en pdf
il ne l'a retourné en quelques jours
l'argent est crédité
[Musique]
la mesure prise par le gouvernement je
c'est du jamais vu
donc c'est un signal fort donné pour
aider le tissu économique local
le prêt garanti par l'état c'est un prêt
à 0 %
les banques octroient un prêt à 0 % le
seul coût pour l'entreprise c'est le
coût de la garantie et c'est 0,25 la
première année et au bout d'un an
l'entreprise à la plusieurs solutions
soit la capacité à rembourser par
anticipation secret très bien soit
l'entreprise souhaite amortir ce crédit
qui a été octroyée et apple l'amortir
sur une durée de un à cinq ans de coût
final c'est une capacité qui est donné à
l'entreprise d'avoir un prêt sur une
durée au total de 6 ans un taux très
faible
parlons culture à présent avec cette
opération lancée par le conseil
départemental en résidence depuis juin
dernier dans les yvelines pour un projet
sur le thème de la paix s'entend après
les traiter de la première guerre
mondiale
l'artiste babette largo a décidé de
réinventer son travail en raison du
confinement l envie donc tous les
yvelinois participer à distance à une
création collective pour immortaliser
cette période c'est jusqu'au 11 avril
2020 que ce soit sous forme de journaux
'la d'enregistrement audio de vidéos de
dessins tous les détails est sur le site
des archives départementales et de son
côté la région elle vient de voter un
fonds d'urgence de 10 millions d'euros
pour le secteur du spectacle vivant
plus de détails avec florence portelli
vice présidente à la région en charge de
la culture elle est interrogée par
aurélie rose avec la crise liée au
public 19 à les structures des
compagnies les artistes qui travaillent
dans le domaine du spectacle vivant qui
est d'ailleurs la catégorie comme
subventionnant puces à la région ile de
france
eh bien ils sont très très fortement
impacté mais parce que évidemment il ya
les annulations de spectacles
donc ça entraîne des conséquences
extrêmement préjudiciable pour ce milieu
et nous avons décidé d aider urgemment
il ya deux idées derrière ce volet le
premier c'est de garantir le versement
des sommes qui auraient été dues si les
prestations s'était déroulée normalement
et ce assez pour toutes les compagnies
structures avec lesquelles on passe des
accords avec les paul et ken on vote des
subventions donc au sein de la région
n'avait voté des subventions pour 2020
pour ses compagnes et ses structures
donc on leur garantit en absence parfois
de service fait le versement de la
totalité de la somme correspondant à la
prestation
et puis à deuxième relais donc ça
prenait 6 9 millions deuxième c'est en
millions d'euros
c'est pour les structures les plus
fragiles avec lesquels on ne travaille
pas forcément c'est vous êtes un artiste
votre compagnie votre association votre
entreprise a prévu un spectacle
et puis évidemment vous avez une perte
énorme anguilles et prix faute de
recettes puisque spectacle est annulé
donc vous pourrez demander le
remboursement à hauteur de six à huit
mille euros pour la perte en billetterie
et si par exemple vous perdez 2000 euros
mais on vous remboursera les 2000 euros
pour ça il faut quand même il faut quand
même avoir un engagement assez certain
si on assure l'emploi
[Musique]
pour nos spectacles vivants 10 millions
d'euros ça nous paraissait être une
somme très importante mais assez
réaliste par rapport aux pertes de toute
façon courant mais nous allons refaire
un point avec les syndicats avec les
différents organismes et dans les autres
secteurs tels de secteur du livre de
secteur des galeries d'art secteur du
cinéma
nous avons déjà des points de travail
des moments de travail avec les
syndicats qui sont prévues certains
d'ailleurs ont déjà commencé et nous
allons pouvoir estimer s'il n'y a encore
besoin de réévaluer notre aide culture
et loisirs également avec la société
asmodée qui a décidé de venir en aide
aux familles pendant cette période de
confinement
la société basée à guyancourt et l'un
des leaders au niveau mondial de
l'édition et de la distribution de jeux
de société et à l'offre dès à présent à
des jeux de son catalogue à télécharger
et à imprimer basé à guyancourt asmodée
diffuse ces jeux de société dans une
cinquantaine de pays à l'entreprise
figure parmi les leaders dans le monde
et durant cette période de confinement
elle vient de lancer print une plaie
d'obole dixit ou encore time line et
unlock six de ses best-sellers sont
disponibles gratuitement une solution
pour s'occuper en famille les cartes de
jeu sont imprimables est similaire à
celle que l'on trouve dans le commerce
des vidéos permettent également de mieux
comprendre les règles
bien que la vente des jeux de société
explose depuis le 16 mars avec une
progression de plus de 80 % à la
fermeture de nombreux points de vente et
les restrictions des ventes en ligne
rendent difficiles les achats d'autres
titres print and play devrait être
disponible en téléchargement prochaine
[Musique]
pour terminer cette édition spéciale du
7 avril nous sommes en ligne à présent
avec le père pierre hervé grosjean a des
gros genre bonjour bonjour vous êtes
curé du groupement paroissial de
montigny voisins-le-bretonneux vous est
aussi secrétaire général de la
commission éthique et politique pour le
diocèse des yvelines c'est en ce moment
la semaine sainte pour les chrétiens ce
moment et qui précède pas qui est
destiné notamment à commémorer la
passion du christ de nombreuses
célébrations ont lieu en temps normal
comment aujourd'hui vous appelez vos
fidèles malgré tout à à célébrer ce
moment
eh bien écoutez c'est vrai que même si
nos églises restent ouvertes vous le
savez les rassemblements ne sont pas
possibles dans cette pub de confinement
et nous chrétiens voulons vraiment vivre
ces règles qui sont imposés à tous bien
sûr et donc il va nous falloir nous
vivons enfin pour chacun d'entre nous de
vivre la semaine sainte
chez nous ce qui est assez particulier
parce que c'est la semaine la plus
importante pour les chrétiens dans
l'année c'est la semaine où on célèbre
les derniers jours du christ sa mort
pour nous et sa résurrection
alors ça veut ce que j'ai dit aux
paroissiens sais que ça peut être
peut-être l'occasion justement de la
vivre de façon un peu renouvelé sans
tomber dans l'habitude chaque année on
vous connaissait un peu par coeur ces
célébrations qui sont très belles mais
là tout d'un coup on va en devant les
vivre chez nous on va peut-être les re
découvrir qu en quelque sorte de
l'intérieur peut-être en lisant en
prenant plus de temps en famille ou en
couple pour lire les textes pour re
découvrir les textes qu'on peut lire
chez soi et tout en étant en communion
je crois que c'est quelque chose qu'on
découvre depuis toutes ces semaines de
confinement la force de la communion de
prière la force de la communion
fraternelle à travers une parole ne sait
avec tout notre pays
on le sent croyants et non croyants on
sent que cette unité entre nous est très
se révèle très importante et très forte
pour pour ce pour mener cette bataille
contre contre l'épidémie
marrant vous nous le dites il n'y aura
pas donc de cérémonie qui se tiendra
avec du public ça va de soi vu les
recommandations et les consignes qui ont
été dictées par le gouvernement
néanmoins il y aura des bénédictions
notamment en ligne jeudi à 10h30 pour
monseigneur aumônier alors monseigneur
aumônier va célébrer la messe
risma la messe chrismale cela mais ce
qui d'habitude chaque année au milieu de
semaine sainte rassemble tous les
prêtres du diocèse et plusieurs milliers
de fidèles au cours de laquelle il
bénies les huiles qui vont servir
ensuite à la confirmation sacrement des
malades et c est donc là il va célébrer
seul dans la cathédrale de versailles
mais ça va être transmis effectivement
pour que tous les les habitants des
yvelines et tous les prêtres des
yvelines puisse être en communion de
prière avec lui et puis je précise aussi
que le diocèse des yvelines a publié
toute une série de documents pour
accompagner justement les fidèles c'est
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure et
concrètes pour que chacun puisse vivre
quel que soit son âge
la semaine sainte chez lui au delà de
cette semaine sainte
aujourd'hui pendant le confinement
comment vous poursuivez vos missions
justement avec les paroissiens avec les
fidèles vont rester en contact malgré
tout alors en l'église et la est là vous
savez elle a toujours cherché au cours
de l'histoire à s'adapter aux situations
qu'elles rencontrent pour continuer
d'accompagner les uns et les autres dans
les joies et les peines que vous pouvez
vivre et donc c'est ce qu'on essaie de
faire alors c'est difficile parce que
nous les prêtres on est vraiment les
hommes de la rencontre
ce qu'on aime faire ces rencontres et
des uns et les autres et donc là ça nous
est interdite en quelque sorte et donc
il nous faut découvrir d'autres moyens
d'accompagner d'encourager de consoler
et de d'encourager oui par par les
moyens en particulier de communication
les uns les autres en essayant que
chacun se sente justement accompagné en
lien je fais j'essaie de faire attention
en particulier aux personnes isolées qui
n'auraient pas justement ces ressources
internet l'autre pour qu'ils aient pas
d'isolement parce que face à une épreuve
on a vraiment besoin d'être ensemble de
se sentir entouré de sentir justement en
communion c'est extrêmement extrêmement
important les églises qui est et reste
ouverte malgré tout ça pour vous à
l'envié quelquefois que ses fidèles bien
sûr il est toujours possible on envoie
quelques uns qui en allant faire leurs
courses avec l'autorisation adéquate ou
en faisant leur petite promenade qui a
autorisé aussi et bien peuvent s'arrêter
à l'église poser un cierge prier
quelques instants y'a jamais plus de 20
personnes
de toute façon et on fait attention mais
c'est aussi important c'est
symboliquement c'est important de même
que j'ai voulu que les cloches continué
à sonner
voyez pour marquer justement que on est
en attente de pouvoir un jour se se
retrouver que tout ça n'est pas terminée
que l'église n'est pas absente de cette
grande épreuve
ll la vie avec avec tout le pays
ça c'est important et puis on reste
aussi disponible je tiens à leur dire
pour les mourants pour accompagner ceux
qui sont au soir de leur vie que ce soit
dans les hôpitaux chez eux ou dans les
maisons de retraite il est toujours
possible et ça c'est reconnu aussi par
là par le gouvernement 1 que les
ministres du culte puissent se rendre au
chevet de ce qu'ils sont en train de
mourir pour que personne ne meurt seul
c'est c'est vraiment ça fait partie de
la dignité de la personne humaine de
pouvoir être entouré jusqu'au bout et
nous serons là pour ça et justement j'ai
une dernière question par rapport à
cette situation aujourd'hui les obsèques
les enterrements se déroule de quelle
manière vous pouvez bien sûr là aussi le
gouvernement a permis cela laissait les
seuls célébration en fonte qui sont
maintenus la célébration des obsèques
alors il ya moins de 20 personnes
donc souvent il ya une des personnes qui
filme et on peut tout à fait faire ça
qui filme les obsèques pour que d'autres
tous les amis puissent regarder cela en
direct sur les réseaux sociaux
et il ya moins de 20 personnes on essaie
d'être séparés les uns des autres d'un
mètre extra on fait attention respectez
mesures sanitaires
mais il est évident que justement dans
cette dans ce temps d'épreuves
il faut accompagner les familles dans le
deuil il faut permettre à chacun de
vivre ces moments-là infiniment
douloureux au mieux et donc nos églises
restent ouvertes pour cela et nous
prêtres nous restons pour cela nous
n'abandonnerons jamais personne merci
beaucoup au père pierre hervé grosjean
d'avoir été en ligne avec nous
aujourd'hui merci à vous je rappelle
donc nous sommes en pleine semaine
sainte il y aura une messe chrismale
avec monseigneur aumônier à la
cathédrale saint louis et ce sera
retransmis sur youtube et facebook
uniquement bien évidemment ce sera sans
son fidèle sans public nous refermons
cette édition spéciale en des voussures
tv 78e demain pour un nouveau point
sur l'actualité dans les yvelines et
d'ici là 24 heures sur 24 sur notre site
internet et sur les réseaux sociaux
également portez vous bien et restez
chez vous
[Musique]